what's poppin rockstars my name is mt
and buckle up my nerd babies because
i've got something nice for you
today hang on just a minute because i
recently had the amazing privilege to be
invited by disney and marvel studios to
chat with professional handsome and
talented writer man michael waldron
during his virtual press tour for the
disney plus series
loki michael waldron is of course the
super chill head writer for loki as well
as the upcoming doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness so
naturally my weird ass self decided to
ask him about
one division a show that ended three
months ago but
more specifically how loki could solve a
big
one division mystery behind marvel's
unexpected boner boner
but before i get into all that i just
want to let you guys know that this
video is brought to you by squarespace
from websites and online stores to
marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run
your business but yes loki one division
boner secrets
play the interview john and obviously
people were quite surprised to find out
that evan peters was ralph boner the
entire time
instead of quicksilver from the fox
x-men films in one division so now that
loki is set to introduce the concept of
variance to the mcu
will we get some sort of explanation for
that phenomenon in one division
explained in loki
you have to have to watch you know
experience that that's the cool thing
about variants
but i don't i don't think i can you know
we'll we'll see uh
how tied in we were with that uh at the
end of all this
hmm an interesting reaction and a
response wouldn't you say
[Music]
that is the cool thing about variants
isn't it now i am willing to bet a
significant amount for my three-digit
savings account that walden's response
to this question is a strong indicator
that roth boner from wandervision will
be revealed as a variant of peter
maximoff aka quicksilver from the fox
x-men films by the end of the loki
series
something that would confirm a strongly
held theory of mine that i've been
screaming to the clouds like a senile
old man about called
the boner effect which basically states
that the same faces
exist throughout the marvel multiverse
but sometimes with different
personalities or roles
but while this isn't an official
confirmation from waldron about anything
you know judging by his i don't wanna
get shot by marvel sniper's
response the suggestion that loki is
shaping up to be
the boner effect the series is pretty
strong with the very concept
of variance in the loki show being the
boner effect
in action so basically what i'm saying
here is is that the loki show will
introduce the concept that steve rogers
and johnny storm killmonger in johnny
storm pietro and craven blade and
cottonmouth moon knight in apocalypse
thanos and cable from deadpool these
will all be revealed to be
boner effect variants of each other tied
together onto the single
sacred multiversal timeline by the
mysterious time keepers
some pretty wild [ __ ] man but hey before
i continue this video i just want to
once again to thank our sponsor of
today's video
squarespace squarespace is the
all-in-one platform to build a beautiful
online presence and run your business
want to start a website for your
business i mean maybe your venom fan art
is about to be a hot ticket now that the
sequel's about to come out and everyone
is in the market for some
slimy toothy paintings because you know
one cannot get enough
teeth in one's life present all of your
cool stuff with squarespace's
professional portfolio designs and
display projects in customizable
galleries
and you can auto post your content to
twitter facebook or tumblr they have
built-in mobile websites and a really
slick mailing list feature to stay in
touch with all of your customers
squarespace will even sell you a url
which is super convenient head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
new rockstar to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain that's
squarespace.com
new rockstars for 10 off your first
purchase the website or
domain but anyways moving on with the
interview i also asked this brilliant
rick and morty writer of a man
about the term nexus that appeared
during the tva's animated presentation
at the beginning of the series premiere
in relation to the last time we heard
the word nexus said in
one division play the clip john i mean
every everything
informs everything else so whether it's
us you know myself communicating with
jack schaefer who was the head writer
of wandavision or more often
it's the creative producers who are
there in the room with us
the marvel executives interfacing with
their colleagues to make sure that
we're all you know telling a cohesive
story alongside one another
but each team is working independently
to make sure that their
project is the best thing it can
possibly be
and then you know naturally they they
all tend to
to fit together and of course since the
man michael waldron has been chosen by
our lord and savior kevin feige himself
to pen
the dr strange two script you know i
just had to ask him about some potential
teases and crumbs for doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness hidden within
loki as well
i think that's something you you'll have
to you have to watch it all and
find out fi find find out if i was that
smart or not and i have a good feeling
that my boy mike waldron
is that smart and judging by this
response i think it's safe to say that
we should
very much be on the lookout for doctor
strange to teases within the loki show
you know like when my wife miss minutes
said that the multiverse could fall into
madness
during the tva video multiverse madness
crumbs doctor strange it's coming but i
can think of few things
more mad than jumping out of a plane you
hijacked with a briefcase full of money
after losing a bet to the asgardian god
of thunder now i don't know about you
i could be in the minority here but i
personally loved how they made an
actual mysterious historical figure loki
all along so i just had to ask michael
waldron if he had any other history
manipulating plans for
where in time is loki san diego and
here's what he said
we talked about a million things in the
writers in the writers room i think we
had a white board just
filled with different historical events
eras places we wanted to go you want to
do something that
that isn't obvious but yet isn't such a
deep cut that nobody can
even identify it as a right as a
historical event so i i think
fortunately with db cooper we we hit a a
nice little bullseye
of just something that's fun to to see
on screen
and of course because marvel loves to
make their end credits so incredibly
detailed your favorite brown nerd just
had to ask about it well
more specifically if there are any
easter eggs within that end credit
sequence
that we should all be keeping an eye out
for that credit sequence is rad i don't
know it's
it's hey look i i would say every frame
of the show
is worth pausing and looking at whether
to look for easter eggs or to just to
luxuriate in the production design that
the
production designer did it's it's all
beautiful
how important is it i don't know time
will tell and finally since i'm sitting
down with the freaking head writer of
loki i thought i'd do the speculating
nerd world a favor by playing a little
speculation game with michael waldron
and well
just take a look i'm going to say a word
or phrase
and you just send me a signal if you
think it's okay for all of us to
speculate
in that direction one a big cameo should
we speculate in that direction speculate
okay tie ins to multiverse of madness
speculate speculate in a way okay king
the conqueror sure speculate away
speculating the way all right mutants
speculate
and uh you know mephisto oh definitely
oh we gonna be speculating
big time speculation and um
how about the builders speculate
oh respect okay okay okay cool so i
didn't really get a lot out of a waldron
there
but he did tell us to speculate about
all those things so
that's what we gonna do because that's
what we do here at new rockstars you
know
we speculation nation but anyways huge
huge thank you to michael waldron for
taking the time to sit down with me this
was my first interview ever in the
history of beyonce's sacred timeline but
michael waldron is such a chill and easy
to talk to dude
for answering the questions that i had
for him that i didn't even need all
those adult diapers that i purchased in
preparation for the interview huh
what i didn't say anything about depends
for men that was you and of course an
even bigger thank you to disney and
marvel studios for inviting new
rockstars in for such a cool interview
you guys are freaking rad and kevin
feige
is my dad so let you guys know that my
black son
my black son but anyways thank you guys
so much for watching this video and be
sure to follow me
mastertainment if you want to you know
hear me ramble about various marvel
theories 24 7 because that's literally
all i do on my twitter because i have a
tweeting problem but most importantly
you can follow new rockstars anywhere we
are on the internet especially on
youtube where you can hit that
notification bell so you can get
notifications anytime we upload a new
video
come on man pretty dope and make sure to
hit up new rockstarsmerch.com so you can
see all of our cool stuff including our
new loki designs and stuff
because we got a lot of cool [ __ ] there
including some miss minutes merch but
you know
don't tell anybody especially you know
my wife's suitors
take it easy everybody
[Music]
you